merci nadia carmel d'être avec nous ce
soir merci beaucoup
le 3 avril 2018 vous étiez sur la route
avec vos trois enfants pour rentrer chez
vous là il ya un orage qui vient
d'éclater
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'étais à
quelques centaines de mètres non
domicile et effectivement il ya eu un
orage très violent
j'ai pu apercevoir une berline noire
arrivé à vive allure
elle arrivait très très vite et je me
suis simplement dit mais elle va si vite
et le temps que ça arrive consciemment à
moi à la quitter sa route pour arriver
en choc frontal sur ma route à man
ça a été un choc d'une rare violence et
ma fille lila trois ans et demi est
décédée une heure après l'accident ente
à adélaïde 26 mois vingt-quatre heures
après mon fils isaac achète à un mois
alors vous avez été réveillé par les
cris de de votre fils tout de suite
après l'accident
vous allez essayer d'ouvrir sa portière
mais la voiture était verrouillé c'est
les gens autour les personnes autour qui
ont qui ont essayé de qui l'ont aidé à
sortir
donc vous avez vu vos filles inerte à ce
moment là votre autre fils blessé c'est
vrai que c'est un témoignage voilà qui
qui nous touche tous et surtout vous
comprenez assez vite que c'est fini pour
vos filles puisque les pompiers mettent
20 minutes à arriver à les prendre en
charge bon ils ont fait leur boulot et
c'est votre ex-mari qui est venu vous
dire que votre fils il a était décédé
c'est exactement ça alors je sais
qu'après des débats aussi virulent
envoyer un paquet comme le mien et mon
espoir c'est assez lourd pour tous pour
tous mais c'est une réalité c'est ce qui
s'est passé effectivement le choc a été
si violent que ça n'a laissé aucune
chance à mes filles et on en mange je me
suis tourné suffit talent alerte mon
enfant de vote isaac qui s'est mis à
pleurer
très très fort puisqu'il avait une
fracture du fémur gauche et c'est une
douleur très bien je me suis retournée
et là effectivement j'ai pu constater
que même si malheureusement la respire
actuel est en arrêt cardio respiratoire
alors à l'hôpital
vous apprenez que le conducteur est dans
une chambre en dessous de la vôtre vous
décidez d'aller le voir
vous arrivez dans sa chambre qu'est ce
que vous lui dites vous savez que c'est
la personne qui a tué aux deux petites
filles et vous trouvez en train de je
crois qu'il était en train de dîner de
ça alors exactement
en fait ce qui s'est passé que c'est que
j'avais des fractures moi même j'étais
blessé j'ai refusé tous les soins donc
j'étais auprès de mes enfants dans les
24 heures qui ont suivi l'accident près
d'adélaïde
puis après d'isaac j'avais néanmoins une
chambre en traumatologie jeunes
occupaient pas en fait c'est pour rester
auprès de mes enfants et etc en irak a
fini par ouvrir les yeux
toutes les informations qu'on me donnait
depuis cinq veaux sont revenus à moi et
donc on m'a expliqué que le conducteur
était effectivement dans le même hôpital
que moi dans la chambre en dessous de la
mienne qui est restée inoccupée
j'étais en chaise roulante à ce
moment-là plâtré à la main et au pied
brisé de partout et je me suis
simplement dit en fait que cette
personne là n'était pas venu à notre
rencontre
oui pour nous présenter ses condoléances
ni pour nous présenter ses excuses ni
lui ni le passager puisqu'il y avait un
passager mes premières pensées ont été
simplement de savoir dans quel état ils
étaient et m'a vite expliqué que le
passage était enfin un état critique et
que le conducteur est évident avait une
fracture de la hanche mais était
conscient et en traumatologie
alors il paraît que quand vous arrivez
dans sa chambre j'ai tu arrives en
fauteuil roulant comme vous le dites ça
à sans agressivité bien sûr vous êtes en
chaîne
parce que vous nous expliquer et paraît
qu'il a eu sur les à l'aide au secours
j'étais en chaise roulante complètement
abattu et fait pousser la porte de sa
chambre avec la tout de suite su que
vous étiez la maman des deux petites
filles la conductrice
il a dit à l'aide au score alors plus
tard vous avez besoin d'en savoir plus
sur le conducteur de la voiture c'est
important pour vous on comprend et vous
apprenez donc il est père de famille
chefs d'entreprise mais surtout que
c'est un multirécidiviste bail qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes sur la
route exactement quand je dis chefs
d'entreprise au père de famille c'est
les responsabilités sur un compte que
j'en pensais pas le sur nos dossiers
on a reçu le procès verbal des semaines
après et là vous voyez en fait son
passif plus de neuf infractions d'excès
de vitesse au delà de 40 kilomètres au
delà de 50 km à deux suspensions de
permis dont une qui lui a valu du coup
quatre mois de suspension de permis au
lieu des trois ans normalement pour ce
type d'infraction ce qui leur a amené à
mai 2018 et notre accident a eu lieu au
mois d'avril 2018 voilà alors vous étiez
sur une départementale le soir du drame
limité à 80 km/heure et un expert a
retenu son 45 km pour la berline du ya
eu de nombreuses expertises comme vous
l'avez indiqué c'était par temps de
pluie
à l'époque la départementale était à 90
km à mais la pluie a appelé à la plus
grande prudence et la vitesse réduite de
80 voire 70 km/ha en fonction de la
visibilité
il ya eu plusieurs expertises certaines
ont déterminé 110 km heure d'autres 144
km ha ouais alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour lui après l'accident et déjà
est ce que vous l'avez recroiser ce que
vous avez eu ce que vous l'avez dit
quelque chose que vous êtes arrivé dans
sa chambre qu est ce qu est ce que vous
l'avez dit simplement parce qu'il avait
commis vous l'avez dit vous avez il
m'avait enlevé mes deux filles
il a des amis vous avez brisé la famille
de mon ex confins vous avez brisé ma
famille de mon conte 20 avril à briser
votre vie qu'est ce qui vous a répondu
alors d'avril à septembre
il a pas eu de suspension de permis pour
le conducteur donc c'est ce que vous
deveniez nous dire les u 6 mois là de sa
wii avant le premier ou la première à la
première sanction en tout cas qui a été
sa suspension de permis pendant six mois
en effet et en décembre vous avez croisé
le conducteur sur la route encore en
excès de vitesse
c'est ça a l'air incroyable il ya une
première audience au mois de décembre
qui la lui a valu en tout cas
l'autorisation de conduire avec eux
qu'ils ne nécessitent pas de permis
ce qui veut dire une voiture est bien
chaud donc une voiture sans permis ses
48 km à sauf qu'on a une seule
départementale pour allier le domicile
et le sien d'aia et on a été doublé par
cette personne sur notre route sur cette
départementale à 75 km à
on a donc fait un dépôt de plainte et à
ce jour on n'a pas de nouvelles du
procureur effectivement cette personne
n'a jamais essayé de venir vous voir de
jeu c'est pas d essayer de trouver les
mots pour pauvres là pour s'excuser même
si c'est inexcusable
jamais elle n'a jamais voulu avoir un
contact avec vous jamais notre histoire
a été diffusée vous le savez sur
beaucoup de personnes m'ont parlé il a
eu plusieurs portes ouvertes
oui on a eu une expertise où il était
présent il ya une reconstitution où il
était comme vous et moi l'un à côté de
l'autre on a eu une audience
il a un avocat on n'a jamais l'être
jamais un mot jamais alors le procès et
jeudi prochains on vous en parlera
d'ailleurs on va suivre la faire on en
parlera d'ailleurs dans ma lance ton
post pour vous dire ce qui s'est passé
vous en attendez quoi ce qu'est ce que
vous voulez vous voulez quoi aujourd'hui
à moyen terme reste de la presse est non
mais ça ça franchement ça ça doit être
mais ça doit être ça aurait dû se faire
tout de suite même une voiturette ni a
été appliquée à partir de septembre donc
six mois après oui mais bon on a été
rétablie
oui exactement ensuite une détention
provisoire sera envisageable il
représente un danger pour nous mais
aussi pour tout est vrai que vous
demandez de la prison ferme
oui on parle de l'application des peines
drastique puisque effectivement elle
encourt sept ans l'avait circonstances
aggravantes et je crois que personne
autour de la table a déjà entendu une
sanction pareil pour un accident de la
route
les peines sont pas appliquées à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui et je pense que si on les
appliquait de manière drastique
on éviterait certaines récidive vous
dites que la prison la prison est un
moment de réflexion en dehors de la
société ou penser que pour lui limite ce
procès que ce serait important qui qui
réfléchissent un petit peu peut-être ce
qu'il a fait c'est une personne qui est
en excès permanent on ne peut parler
peut-être même de dépendance à la
vitesse comme on pourrait parler de
dépendance à l'alcool ou à la drogue et
qu'effectivement ce temps de réflexion
en dehors de la société est primordial
je pense même que c'est des personnes
qui nécessitent un suivi psychologique
peut-être de rencontrer un psychiatre et
seule cette personne là ni vous ni moi
ni un je ne peux dire si cette personne
est apte ou inapte à la conduite
naturelle un psychiatre nadia
aujourd'hui
pensez tous les jours à cette personne
est ce que vous vous dites lui
aujourd'hui il continue à vivre sa vie
et moi ma vie est brisée
est ce que je pense je tuais jeu rallye
non je pense tous les jours à mes deux
petites filles elles sont partout alors
aujourd'hui on a envie de me poser la
question comment surmonter un tel drame
moi je vous vois en parle et mine de
rien ce soir vous arrivez à en parler et
aujourd'hui vous vous battez
certainement pour que ça n'arrive pas à
d'autres personnes que toutes ces
personnes qui sont dans l'excès puissent
être mises voit la horde et admire
aujourd'hui comment on arrive à se
relever d'un tel drame dont dont on très
bas et on s'accroche à ce que isaac
cette accroche nature autre petit garçon
exactement il est certainement même plus
fort que nous et vous tenez un pas après
l'autre
après une longue fuite et puis paris que
vous avez vous avez aussi puiser des
ressources aussi vous êtes approcher
d'autres personnes qui ont connu le même
drame que vous on a eu un soutien
formidable de la part d'inconnus de la
part du corps médical de la part de tous
niveaux nettement il n'y a pas une
personne qui ne s'est pas mobilisée pour
nous soutenir
et ça a été un soutien précieux pour
nous de pouvoir échanger avec d'autres
personnes qui avaient vécu des drames on
est similaire au vôtre ça vous happe
sorte de message des personnes qui ont
vécu un drame similaire des personnes
comme vous qui n'ont pas envie de vivre
un drame similaire du grand parents des
hommes des femmes
on se retrouve tous dans notre accident
alors vous avez tous entendu le
témoignage de nadia c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on se pose la question
est ce que les mesures qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement basque elles
suffisent
voilà et est ce que la mortalité sur les
routes traduit-elle un échec du
gouvernement et surtout moi aussi j'ai
envie qu'on s'intéresse deux petites
secondes aussi aux sanctions il ne rien
parce que ce qui a fait que ce drame est
arrivé aussi c'est que la personne est
un récidiviste
voilà et que mine de rien à ce niveau là
pense qu'il faut tout simplement retiré
le permis à vie et peut-être pensé à
retirer le permis à vie à certaines
personnes du mois m bah oui et là c'est
terrible parce que quelle que soit la
limite de vitesse
en fait ce fou cette personne aurait
pris sa voiture de toute façon donc on
peut mettre 80 78 90
le fait qu'ils aient la possibilité de
prendre un véhicule maintenant on
appelle aussi des voitures est lent mais
bien sûr le monde on peut conduire une
voiture à 45 kilomètres heure on peut
tuer quelqu'un à 40 bien sûr le mettra
donc le tout c'est d'appliquer les
peines d'être le plus ferme possible
et puis de lutter contre 6 d'alcool au
volant les stupéfiants les téléphones ya
une vrai qu'on a un vrai combat et c'est
vrai que ces histoires de 80 kilomètres
heure bah c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt est à mon sens on n'a pas été
assez fort on avait juste voulu mettre
des radars pour faire plaisir à tout le
monde alors qu'en réalité il faut
adapter au cas par cas et là clairement
dans leur histoire même si sept ans de
prison
excusez moi c'est ans de prison ça me
parait bidon c'est en prison pour avoir
tué deux personnes
on est en récidiviste avec des
circonstances aggravantes alors on parle
d'évaluation psychiatrique
je pense que la psychiatrie a bon dos
c'est facile de dire qu'il était fragile
mais très certainement que c'est juste
quelqu'un de mauvais parce que ça existe
donc je pense qu'il faut des peines
fermes il faut vraiment aller faire
appliquer ses peines et que ce genre de
personne n'est plus jamais accès un
volant tout simplement quand je parle de
psychiatrie charles pas de fragilité en
fait d'esprit au contraire je pense que
justement la différence peut-être avec
certains autres actes de violence sur la
route parce qu'on a je parle de violence
routière et dans l'outil broutier c'est
des actes qui sont délibérées et donc de
ce fait je pense que comme j'ai parlé de
l'alcool ou de la drogue et une
dépendance et cette dépendance là elle
doit être traitée et ses bas de la
fragilité je pense que sincèrement c'est
peut-être un excès une violence
simplement il faut traiter eric naulleau
mais d'abord j'aurais dire que ce que
vous avez vécu ce que vous avez éprouvé
c'est une douleur inimaginable et je
suis très impressionné par le calme et
la sérénité avec la lesquels vous vous
évoquer ce drame je peux même pas
imaginer que ça arrive des pères et des
mères de famille ici on se met tous à
votre place mais ce que je trouve de
encore plus tragique dans cette histoire
c'est que il ya que deux moyens de faire
reculer la mortalité sur les routes
c'est de médiatiser les témoignages
comme le vôtre aussi tragique soit-il
et puis la répression parce que il ya eu
d'abord et à chaque étape de la
répression il ya de moins en moins de
morts mais à chaque étape de la
répression 7
répression et contester on a contesté
les ceintures de sécurité
on a contesté l'alcoolémie et là les 80
km/h sont contestés aussi
or il ya une remontée du nombre des
morts sur les routes qui a correspondu à
la vandalisation des radars et c'est ça
qui m'enrage c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'on ne tire pas les leçons et que tant
que ce votre témoignage ne sera pas
parvenu à tout le monde
on continuera à dénier que la vitesse
est un facteur particulièrement
important et mortifère et est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas un peu découragé quand
vous voyez la polémique autour des 80 km
heure où le gouvernement en fait fait
marche arrière en fait sous la pression
du lobby de lobby ou de l'opinion
publique qui est concrètement vous êtes
médecin urgentiste à 80 km à on peut
sauver des vies à 90 sont
raisonnablement je peux qu'indiqué qu'à
80 km ha c'est profitable à tous
toujours est il qu'à 9 français sur 10
qui sont contre le 80 km ha c'est bien
car en fait les personnes peut-être
s'enorgueillissent et continuer à
accélérer
parce qu'on leur impose quelque chose je
pense qu'en fait on obtiendrait les
choses plus profitable pour tous par la
pédagogie et par l'application de ces
textes de loi il ya des personnes qui
sont penchés dessus vous êtes avocate
il ya des personnes qui créent ces lois
il ya des personnes qui les imposent
normalement et elle ce ne sont jamais
appliquées pourquoi moi je n'ai pas la
réponse peut-être que vous vous lavez
moi je n'ai pas la réponse aux calories
donc pas appliquée d'abord il ya une
politique pénale vise à vide de la route
qui est très singulière on a beaucoup
parlé encore une fois une question de
vocabulaire d' accidents de la route ont
dit les accidents espace défendra c'est
un accident
non vous vous avez utilisé une
terminologie très différent vous dites
violence routière vous dites homicide ce
sans doute y est c'est vrai que déjà on
change de braquet se dire sur la
politique pénale
ça c'est très important parce que quand
aulas on va dire peut-être à la maison
il ya des téléspectateurs qui se disent
ah mais la vie du chauffeur aussi a été
ruinée a été gâchée et ça je ne doute
pas de ça je pense qu'effectivement sa
vie a changé
il peut pas les responsables mais les
responsables
il arrive pas il faut effectivement que
sa peine soit appliquée simplement comme
les scieries l'étoile qu'est ce que vous
dit traquer les vrais il faut arrêter de
parler dans ce cas là d'un axe
donc mine de rien otc pour un accident
c'est vrai qu'elle vous parler
d'homicide ou qu'un accident prévisible
et évitable la voie sur 2 dont il ya une
notion endroit celle arme par
destination et c'est à dire qu'en fait
il ya des armes qui sont des fusils des
doigts la des couteaux qu'il ya des
choses là je pense que ça l'a jamais
vous paludate très fort mon voisin ça
devient une arme par destination
une voiture qui roule vite est une arme
par destination et plus vous roulez vite
et c'est ça que les gens doivent
comprendre plus vous roulez vite plus
vous êtes dans une situation où vous
risquez de devenir une arme et contre
intuitivement c'est pas dans la roue
droite où il ya beaucoup de visibilité
qu'il ya le moins de risque contre
intuitivement c'est plus dans la route
sinueuse où vous allez est attentif
d'autant que vous n'êtes que ya moins de
risques parce que sur la route droite
vous relâcher un petit peu vous dit
c'est bon là c'est facile
donc allez jaja puis en oeuvre dans la
[ __ ] est il donc il ya un changement
culturel profond et merci merci
infiniment de deux doses et venir
témoigner pour nous tous sauf en est on
est on est parent enfin alors les gens à
la maison ce que vous avez vécu un enfer
horrible messieurs il faut qu'il existe
ce transfert parce que lille à adélaïde
et sachs aurait pu être vos enfants donc
il faut qu'il existe ce transfert il est
précieux eric revel ce que dira qu'elle
me sens très juste et d'ailleurs dans
votre livre vous parlez de cette arme
fait vous comparez la voiture un
revolver oui cette violence routière
il me semble qu'elle devrait avoir une
législation particulière parce que votre
votre cas est absolument incroyable ce
multirécidiviste il aurait pu tuer trois
fois ou plusieurs fois donc imaginé une
méditation sur la violence routière arme
par destination à dire à quel avec avec
justesse ça me semble très juste et je
voulais juste vous dire parce que j'ai
lu lui mais j'avais vraiment enfin les
larmes aux yeux passent comme le diéri
qu'on est tous des pères et des mères et
je voulais je vais vous poser une seule
question je ne poserai pas plus
comment est ce que vous avez trouvé la
force d'écrire ce livre tout simplement
je souhaite qu'aucun aucune personne ni
mes proches ou vous autour de la table
où vous dans le public que vous ayez un
livre un pareil drame mais jamais
c'est une peine qui est pérenne
éternelle et y'a rien qui le soignent ça
je vous souhaite jamais de vivre ça tout
simplement
donc j'ai écrit ce livre la peau qui
soit profitable à tous vraiment karim
c'est compliqué parce que moi j'ai
rencontré nadia tout à l'heure donc sur
un plateau notre plateau télé où on a
échangé on est arrivé à l'émission
ensemble monchatre bouleversante et en
même temps le même pression non quoi
bouleversante et parce que parce que ce
qu'a vécu on est comme on l'a dit
laquelle on est père et mère de famille
de que on se dit ça pourrait nous
arriver ça aurait pu arriver ça pourrait
nous arriver qui est impressionné parce
que à la force de s'engager à la force
décret en bouquin de venir nous voir de
que je me dis je me dis franchement il
faut elle va chercher ces ressources là
moi j'ai envie de faire passer un
message ce soir par rapport à sa venue
j'ai envie de dire à ceux qui nous
gouvernent de queue mais peut-être qu'il
faut qu'ils écoutent aussi ce genre de
témoignages il faut qu'ils reçoivent
parce qu'elle a écrit au président de la
république elle fait des propositions de
queue et je crois que si j'ai mis 6 gmi
oui à as qu à ce que ça traduit un échec
du gouvernement c'est parce que je crois
qu'on a un code pénal dans notre pays il
est fait pour être appliquée il n'est
pas fait notamment sur les violences
routières ce que j'appellerais moins
deux mois la criminalité routière parce
que mon et ccc une cinq crimes qu'ils
aient commis bien sûr dès qu' il faut
appliquer les peines on ne peut pas
faire preuve de laxisme ne peuvent pas à
faire preuve de je dirais de comment
dirais-je de laisser aller sur ce sujet
là et après je crois que votre présence
ce soir c'est la meilleure campagne de
sécurité routière qui puisse exister
parce que je ceux qui nous regardent
ceux qui nous écoutent touchés ils vont
se dire que ça aurait pu être moi ça
pourrait être moi
après je veux pas dire que c'est que la
foi du gouvernement parce que je veux
aussi qu'on met le doigt sur la
responsabilité individuelle que le
gouvernement y met en place une
politique de calavi communiante des
faiblesses mais aussi commerçants dont
il recule le gouvernement
il recule mais ceux qui sont tentés par
des comportements inacceptables dort
aussi reculé mais pas seulement
eric que tu as un mec comme ça qu'ils
multirisques masse et sa wii depuis
multirécidiviste tu peux faire ce que tu
veux la guerre tu peux mettre le cadre
lichette bien sûr ce genre de mec il
passera à travers tant qu' il n'y a
qu'une chose c'est qu'ils la répression
ces gens-là rivasi il a fait une
proposition qui est importante il faut
leur enlever le permis à vie
et s'il doit faire de la prison parce
que le code pénal l'exigent il faut
qu'ils en fassent sont assez claires il
faut les pousser à un moment donné ces
gens là pourquoi à réfléchir avant n'est
pas prêt pour pourquoi pourquoi c'est
pas fait ça elle renseigne et raquel
garrido la barque système pénal mais ça
date pas seulement de ce gouvernement
c'est pour ça que je réponds que non
parce qu'on peut pas attribuer à ce
gouvernement en particulier ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui et je pense que
effectivement votre témoignage madame
vous êtes tellement courageuse
c'est très difficile de parler derrière
vous mais votre témoignage
effectivement créé un choc et c'est ce
qu'il faut faire je pense qu'il faut
revenir justement à ces campagnes choc
on avait un moment à la télévision et
qui mettait la réalité en face aux gens
qui prennent leur voiture et c'est vrai
que quand vous êtes dans votre salon
n'avait pas envie de voir parfois des
images d'accidents des images de ce
qu'ils étaient c'était très très dur
mais d'un autre côté je pense que s'il
ya que comme ça qu'on éveillera et que
les gens pourront vraiment prendre
conscience du danger et de la réalité de
la télé terrible réalité de toutes ces
victimes et il faut en revenir à ça est
vraiment en parler le plus en plus parce
qu'une responsabilité individuelle
effectivement on pourra jamais n'importe
quel gouvernement mais même s'il
sanctionne dû remettre derrière chaque
conducteur quelqu'un plus on va se
mettre à la place de nadia qui elle un
calme vraiment je vous admire et jouets
et c'est vrai que c'est un problème mais
un moment on a envie d'en vouloir à
quelqu'un
mine de rien nous aussi autour de la
table les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent ils se disent on a envie d'en
vouloir à quelqu'un on envie de dire se
dire qui sont les responsables
voilà bah alors lui parce que c'est pas
un cas isolé
aujourd'hui donc est ce que c'est la
justice est ce que c'est le gouvernement
s qui voilà c
à dire qu'est ce qu'elle en pense est ce
que vous en pensez vous à dire je crois
qu'on peut s'améliorer on est dans un
système qui est perfectible et on peut
pas être parfait partout et
qu'aujourd'hui
j'élève ma voix j'essaye de m'exprimer
pour toutes ces victimes et pour toutes
les victimes potentielles et je fais des
propositions
alors peut-être qu'elles ne sont pas
excellentes ou parfaite mais elles ont
même au moins le mérite d'exister et il
faudrait que quelqu'un les regardent se
penche dessus parce que peut-être que
d'autres victimes n'ont pas eu la force
de faire ce que je fais là et je le
comprends parce que c'est une douleur
telle qu'on ne peut pas tous trouver des
ressources pour faire ça parce que ça en
donnant pour d'autres choses juste que
quelqu'un regarde ces propositions alors
vos propositions vous avez à vous avez
adressé une lettre ouverte au
gouvernement
application drastique des peines lutte
contre la récidive responsabilisation
des assurances pose de caméras
embarquées dans les voitures
apprentissage obligatoire des gestes de
secours vous avez donc écrit cette
lettre ouverte vous attendez donc des
réponses
agathe vous qu'est ce que vous dites
pour vous qui sont les responsables
je ne suis pas maman mais je n'en suis
pas moins bouleversé par par le drame
que vous avez vécu et ce qui me frappe
ce soir au delà de votre dignité qui me
paraît exceptionnelle c'est les lacunes
les failles même que vous pointez
dans notre système légales et
judiciaires parce que je pense même que
au delà d'appliquer drastiquement ce qui
est prévu par par nos textes de loin je
pense qu'il faudrait même durcir les
peines qui ne sont même pas encore
appliqué ce que quand vous nous dites qu
après ce drame qui est survenu dans
votre vie cette personne au volant de sa
voiture a pu continuer de conduire
même si ce n'est qu'une voiture est pour
nous ça paraît invraisemblable avons
nous dit que le procès qui va se tenir
là dans les prochains jours et dont on
attend le dénouement avec impatience ce
n'est même pas sûr que cette personne
fasse de la prison
deux petites filles ont été tués nous
paraît invraisemblable
donc je suis je suis très très peinée
très mal à l'aise avec ça quel guerrier
ou est-ce que il est ce qu'on peut me
remettre cette personne en détention
directement on doit attendre le procès
parce que mine de rien à plein de gens
voilà choix sur les réseaux sociaux qui
disent elles auraient dû est en
détention bien sûr directement après
après l'accident sur le plan après
l'homicide d'ailleurs du droit bien
entendu il est toujours possible de
mettre quelqu'un en détention provisoire
il ya énormément de personnes dans les
prisons françaises qui sont là avant
jugement sur tout l'historique qui ont
éclos et on tournait suivi exactement et
qui ont pas fait des choses comme ça une
partisane de la détention provisoire
avant jugement mais il ya des critères
et des conditions objectives et
effectivement le risque de mise en péril
de la vie d'autrui fait partie de ces
choses là où il ya moi je vois les
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le monde dit on voit nadia la peine
de nadia on voit mais aussi la force de
nadia tout le monde
réa j ai dit comment cette personne là
peut vivre normalement continuer à
conduire continuer à avoir une activité
continue la vie normalement et et voilà
et attendre gentiment le pro series la
mine de rien la lenteur de la justice
alors il ya mais au delà de au delà de
du comportement de la justice
il ya derrière une faiblesse absolument
fondamental de l'état que ce soit ce
gouvernement les gouvernements
antérieurs vis-à-vis comment le nommer
du lobby de la voiture c'est à dire que
la voiture c'est un totem c'est à dire
qu encore chez pour des raisons
économiques alors parce que ça
représente en gros morceaux du pib ça
représente des emplois dont quelque
sorte d'ample un tronc partie mangane
grosses faiblesses voiture alors celui
qui la poussa attends attends attends je
pardonne moi mais on aurait pu imposer
législativement aux industriels de déjà
limité techniquement les voitures il ya
des voitures qui peuvent monter jusqu'à
180 200 220 240 pourquoi est-ce que ça
c'est la responsabilité je suis pas
d'accord avec ça il ya des sources
internes les aliens les industriels
ça fait dix ans qu'on se pose en font
les industriels pardonnez-moi joue sur
ce côté la recherche de la vitesse le
mec avec sa bagnole sont 4 apple d'un me
mettre avec sa voiture le côté le mec
qui s'identifie avec ça avec sa voiture
et ils veulent pas des voitures qui ne
montrent pas très vite parce qu'ils
savent à baisser les ventes s'abaisse
culture de la vitesse d'un petit but est
là autour et donc c'est un problème et
c'est pas le seul compartiment plus là
dessus dans lequel il ya il ya des
agents qui sont contradictoires du
gouvernement quant au gouvernement il
dit aller chercher du boulot à 100 km de
chez vous quand il dit travailler la
nuit le travail et des heures sup
tout ça c'est accidentogène voir là on
parle d'études sur l'accidentologie
c'est quand vous conduisez fatigué vous
avez vous êtes mais là ça vient
la lazio mais par des personnes facile
de se cacher derrière un grand criminel
pour pas abordé la question oui mais oui
comment nous tous moi je voulais revenir
sur un point que vous avez évoquées par
rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure la dépendance à la vitesse et le
fait de responsabiliser les
constructeurs ou ce genre de choses pour
moi
on oublie l'outil c'est à dire la
voiture la voiture peut devenir une arme
comme vous pouvez avoir un permis
d'armes de port d'armé si vous tiriez
par votre fenêtre tous les matins on
dirait que vous êtes un forcené
si la balle se perdait chez votre voisin
on dit pas la même chose effectivement
que pour un accident de la route et on
dit c'est simplement un accident pour
moi la responsabilité en incombe aussi
aux assurances vous êtes tous assurés
quand vous avez un vécu et aujourd'hui
ils ont une part de responsabilité dans
les axes y passe composé de sept
personnes dans l'acquis multirécidiviste
n'aurait jamais dû coup bas pour pouvoir
assurer sa voiture voilà exactement ils
sentent bien évidemment mais voilà c'est
vrai qu'il ya des initiations peut-être
à trouver et avec les assurances pour
dire voilà un mec qui est
multirécidiviste déjà pour moi il doit
pas conduire mais aussi peut-être on
peut il peut avoir même mené au niveau
des assurances comment expliquer je ne
suis pas pour la perpétuité la chaise
électrique ce n'est pas ma démarche du
tout et je pense au contraire ce que
vous disiez d'augmenter les peines je
suis pas certaine en fait je pense que
vous déjà les appliquer voilà je sors
les appliquer permettent d'avoir sept
ans de réflexion et ce suivi et on
obtiendra certainement des résultats
plus probants racines moi je suis pour
déjà j'ai lu votre livre je les refermer
parce que j'ai commencé à pleurer dès la
première page je confesse que j'avais ma
fille en face de moi et j'ai fini de le
lire lorsque ma fille était couché j'ai
quand même pleuré respect émotions
indignation mais réflexion et je suis
pas la politique de la sanction et pour
la politique de l'éducation l'éducation
comme vous faites aujourd'hui vous
exprimer et je trouve que des
témoignages comme le vôtre on en a
besoin dans les médias et c'est très
puissant que vous soyez là ce soir
ce super la politique de la sanction
1973 première fois on a commencé à
prendre des sanctions contre la vitesse
port de la ceinture
on avait seize mille morts par an anne
et 2018 il faut quand même le rappeler
c'est sous ce gouvernement actuel mais
faut quand même rappeler que celle de
l'année de il ya eu le moins de man 2
historique voilà sur les routes et on
était à 16 me on est environ 3003
le trop on n'a rien on est on est en en
hausse 1 on est en hausse d'hier est
quand même de 18% 17% 744% 44 de plus
que l'année dernière
et c'est en dessous de 2016 et 2017 il
n'empêche que je trouve que c'est très
important la politique de la sanction et
que cet homme reste un meurtrier et la
place des arts trier pour moi est en
prison juste quand on parle de chiffres
on dit 45 de plus 30 de plus en fait
dans la tête des gens ça marque pas une
seule de votre histoire bouleverse tout
bien sûr
donc nous on a habitué aux chiffres
aient eu un mort vivement des cours
d'une quand on dit il y en a 35 et 35
morts de plus ça paraît anodin mais
c'est qu'ils brisaient 35 familles ou
même s'ils n'ont pas de famille peu
importe mais nous avait proposé 5 vous
avez cinq propositions que cyril vous
avez lu mais très concret très simples à
appliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on le fait
pas mettre des radars ça a l'air facile
mais ce que vous proposez sur la
pédagogie avec les gestes de premiers
secours faire appliquer des peines
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne fait pas il
bosse à quoi en fait en vrai c'est quoi
alors c'est pas ça leur job normalement
c'est 2-2 d'écouter ce que les citoyens
ont à proposer et puis d'appliquer des
choses de bon sens donc ça parce que
c'est grave at il a écrit un courrier il
faut au moins qu'elles soient reçues
quoi mais qu'ils entendent déjà 500
émissions
voilà va faire que peut-être des
habitables la regarde ce soir
--peut-être vont vous contacter pour
vous recevoir et peut-être essayer de
voir comment on peut mettre vos
solutions vos idées voilà pratique voilà
en pratique et peut-être vous faire
rencontrer peut-être des groupes de
travail avec qui vous pourriez
travailler sur sur la sécurité routière
allons avoir ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs devaient oui à 75% 25
25% nous voilà donc pour les
téléspectateurs le gouvernement voilà la
hausse de la mortalité sur les routes
est un échec du gouvernement
voilà donc à 64% à dia carmel elle sait
mais très très fort c'est votre livre
j'ai une dernière question opposés parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez de la
haye nous en voulaient à quelqu'un ou
est ce que vous dites là aujourd'hui ma
vie c'est plus d'essayer que tout cela
ne se reproduise plus et d'essayer
d'avancer pour les autres je n'ai pas
élevé mes enfants de cette manière je
leur ai toujours après à être poli à
être lanthier et
je souhaite élever isaac de la même
manière que j'ai élevé lilas et adelaïde
ça me ressemblerait pas de leur
apprendre la violence ou sus de la
colère ce serait pas profitable pour eux
et je crois que tout parent quand il
décide d'avoir un enfant il veut le voir
grandir dans un monde juste paisible et
bienveillant et on essaye de les élever
du mieux qu'on peut
j'aimerais juste qu'en fait on se sent
tous en sécurité sur nos routes
simplement si vous avez quelque chose à
dire un message à faire passer aux
multirécidivistes qui a commis sept
sites homicide lui diriez quoi
aujourd'hui telles que converse et de se
faire soigner en ce qu'il est dépendant
la vitesse vraiment vous pourriez avoir
une discussion avec lui où ce sera
possible
c'est [ __ ] de la discussion
aujourd'hui c'était quelqu'un qui a
normalement la tête sur les épaules
il est père de famille un an et demi
après ça n'a pas le même poids ou la
même pas là il a eu des portes ouvertes
vous apprendrez le procès qui va se
dérouler jeudi prochain so lu ment pas
j'appréhende et l'annoncent pour lille à
appréhender l'annoncent pour adélaïde
c'est la continuité pour moi de procès
merci nadia carmel d'avoir intégré
[Applaudissements]